the new console generation is nearly
upon us which means you're probably
wondering exactly what you'll be able to
play on your fancy new PS 5 if you
missed our video on all the games that
have been announced for the Xbox series
X make sure you check that out but since
you here let's run down all the games
that have been confirmed for the PS 5 so
far including those featured in Sony's
PS 5 reveal event buckle up because boy
do we have a lot to get through first up
your wait for a new Assassin's Creed is
up soon as it has been confirmed that
Valhalla will be a launch title for the
PS 5 the Viking rific installment will
introduce a new protagonist with their
own massive adventure that's sure to eat
up dozens of hours of your life as the
latest entry in the off-road racing
series dirt 5 is shifting gears into the
new generation of Sony consoles to
satisfy your driving game cravings
developer Codemasters has said there
will be new features and innovations and
a voice actors Troy Baker and Nolan
North are contributing to the game's
career mode elsewhere in the realm of
fast cars polyphony digital Gran Turismo
7 is coming to PS 5 with a campaign mode
and all that gorgeous racing action
you've come to expect from the series no
need to be concerned guardians destiny 2
will be on PS 5 it actually didn't
appear at Sony's PS 5 reveal event so we
aren't exactly sure when it will arrive
but be sure it will be on the platform
if you're looking for a little more
certainty though one of the biggest
games in the world right now will be a
PS 5 launch title yep fortnight we'll be
there for you from the get-go and it's
going to support cross play between all
platforms and across generations
epic also confirmed that fortnight will
offer cross progression so you won't
lose your account items or progress if
you choose to upgrade there's also a
plan to migrate the game to Unreal
Engine 5 in 2021 fortnight isn't the
only game you've likely already played
coming to the next-gen console though
Sony kicked off their PS 5 reveal event
with a trailer for grand theft order 5
announcing an enhanced and expanded
version will come to PS 5 in 2021 not
only that but GTA online will be free to
all PS 5 owners at launch PS possible
still be required however if your spidey
senses are tingling that's probably
because Spider Man Miles Morales is
coming to
yes five this holiday season the game is
a follow up to 2018 s Marvel's
spider-man you can check out the full
reveal trailer from Sony's PS 5 reveal
event another announcement from the
reveal event was a new Ratchet and Clank
game called rift a pot insomniac showed
off the gameplay and cinematics from the
game which has been built from the
ground up PS 5 Square Enix and luminous
productions also showed off project
Athea that's currently a working title
but it'll be a PS 5 exclusive featuring
dragon's ferocious dogs a super top
heroine and it's written in part by Gary
Whitta if you're more of a cat person
check out stray Annapurna interactive
cyberpunk adventure set in a world where
humans have died off but cats are doing
just fine
the cinematic trailer revealed the game
is jus in 2021 Sony also showed a
fraternal a game by resogun develop a
house mock that is set on an alien
planet where the protagonist appears to
be stuck in a edge of tomorrow type
situation where she repeats the same
events but the planet changes each time
she dies the third-person shooter will
be exclusive to PS 5 sumo digital
reveals sac boys triumphant return in
Sackboy a big adventure that appears to
be packed with all the platforming you'd
expect though on PS 5 it'll be 3d
platforming instead the 2d action from
the first three games if you're looking
for something a little edgier Bethesda
and tango gameworks gave us a new look
at Shinji Mikami's ghost Wyatt Tokyo we
finally got a glimpse of the PS 5
exclusives gameplay that features
first-person melee and magic action as
well as some truly creepy demonic
creatures in the realm of rocket League
and twisted metal lucid games premiered
in action sports game called Destruction
Allstars
that's riddled with destructible
characters as well as on foot characters
next up is an adventure from ember lab
called Keena bridge of spirits the game
has a pigsty aesthetic and features a
bow toting heroine exploring a vibrant
magical game world with plenty of
fascinating environments to explore and
transform another fantastical adventure
coming to the PS 5 is goodbye volcano
high it features a unique art style and
appears to be an emotional title set as
develop a co-op puts it
at the end of an era Sony's ps5 reveal
had a ton of other games to show off -
including a new odd world game called
soul storm a moody new game from super
brothers called jet the far shore that
seems to have some gorgeous visuals and
solar ash the intriguing new game from
the creators of hyper light drifter -
out in 2021 other brand-new glimpses
during the ps5 reveal included the
bizarre and charming bug snacks in
development at the same studio that made
Octodad a new Astro bot game called
Astros playroom and an adventure game
called little devil inside which
features stealth exploration combat and
hunting games and returning franchises
that are headed to PS 5 include hitman
three which is replete with different
settings and will conclude the reboot -
trilogy you can expect it to launch next
January on top of that is NBA 2k 21 that
showed off its newest and realist sweat
tech and sim basketball as well Resident
Evil 8 village also made its debut
during the PS 5 showcase the new horror
entry will be in first person just like
resi 7 and looks like it'll be upping
the ante on it's creepy setting and
doing something strange with series hero
Chris Redfield it's - out in 2021 we
also go to look at prague motto a
post-apocalyptic game from capcom set in
a world with holographic cats the sci-fi
game is largely a mystery at the moment
but we know it'll be out in 2022
speaking of the post apocalypse horizon
forbidden West the sequel to horizon
zero dawn was also revealed the lush
environments and mechanical critters you
come to expect are making a return as is
fan favorite protagonist alloy now for
something completely different
counterplay games is working with
gearbox and a fantasy action RPG that's
exclusively headed to the PS 5 called
God fall the game is described as a luta
slasher which will support single-player
and co-op where you can join a group of
up to three players to take on more
threatening foes daedalic entertainment
the creators of Deponia have announced
it's developing a Lord of the Rings game
centered around Gollum little is known
about the game just yet
except that much like the sewers of the
titles you can expect an adventure game
and it's true out sometime in 2021
Bulletstorm and Gears of War
judgment developer people can fly is
teaming up with Square Enix for yet
another ps5 game Jew out late this year
called outriders outriders is a cover
shooter that will apparently push you to
hop out from behind those chest high
walls and equip you with a bunch of
unique abilities to help get the job
done
turns out the rumors were true and a
remake to Demon Souls is in the works
From Software's classic is getting a
visual upgrade and a new mode courtesy
of Blue Point games the team behind the
excellent Shadow of the Colossus remake
for more details be sure to check back
with us Arkane Studios once again showed
off its PS 5 exclusive death bloop the
game where two assassins are engaged in
an ongoing jewel the game features are
Kane's signature style in stealth and
will be out for the holiday season this
year bandai namco revealed their
upcoming title scarlet nexus will also
arrive on PS 5 it's an action adventure
set in the futuristic city of new high
Macha where you'll step into the shoes
of an up-and-coming soldier gifted with
psychokinetic powers the visuals are
bright and colorful and the monster
designs appear truly creepy vampire the
masquerade bloodlines - the sequel to
the cult classic will also be making its
way to PS 5 paradoxus said your choices
plots and schemes will change the
balance of power in vampire riddled
Seattle so that'll be one to watch if
you're a creature of the night fan we're
yet to find out if watchdogs legion will
be a ps5 launch title but it will be
coming to the platform as legion is set
to allow you to control any NPC in the
game world the extra power of the PS 5
should be a useful addition anglers can
also breathe a sigh of relief ultimate
fishing simulator 2 is hitting the PS 5
in 2021 the sequel is being developed by
master code and promises a number of
improvements like better graphics a
third-person camera and improved fish AI
I don't personally play fishing games
but I bet if you do that all sounds very
exciting it may have been officially
revealed during the Xbox series X
presentation but deep Silva's upcoming
space shooter chorus will also be coming
to PS 5 the dark sci-fi title follows
Nara and her sentient Starfighter ship
forsaken as they clash with foes and
traverse the galaxy it's also drought in
2021 there have been fairly confident
murmurings that games including
battlefield six cyberpunk 2077 warframe
and others will be making their way to
PS 5 but were yet to get an official
announcement on any of those stay tuned
to guess what and you'll know everything
you'll be able to play on your shiny new
console of choice as soon as we do
[Music]
you
[Music]